les maracas et des collations dans des
contenants réutilisables bien sûr
isabelle c'est jacques et ses filles se
préparent à les marchés pour la planète
l'important pour les enfants les
générations futures faire plus attention
à l'environnement parce que la planète
j'aurais va mourir cause la pollution
la petite famille du quartier rosemont
posent des gestes au quotidien pour
l'environnement on essaie d'acheter de
moins en moins d'aliments emballés
individuel les lunchs zéro déchet chez
les saint jacques la marche
d'aujourd'hui est une affaire de filles
à l'arrêt d'autobus madeleine la sorte
d'isabelle se joint au groupe avec ses
enfants et elles ne sont pas les seuls à
profiter de cette journée pédagogique
pour participer à l'événement l'autobus
est rempli d'autres familles du quartier
un virus ait étudié à quelques coins de
rue de la grette attenberg se prépare à
ouvrir la marche qui veut goûter à des
gens de tous âges de toutes les
générations
c'est une très belle journée dit m
adolescente suédoise figure de proue du
mouvement vendredi pour l'avenir inspire
les jeunes d'ici pour elle c'est
important là
la natation
et elle est vraiment courage ace alors
que des dizaines de milliers de
personnes convergent vers le point de
départ mamie arrive enfin
elle s'est laissé convaincre par ses
filles pour ses petits enfants ils ont
évité moment est-ce que tu venais avec
nous à la marche pour le climat j'espère
oui c'est vrai c'est pour toutes nos
générations mais surtout nos petits
enfants qui vont vivre sur la planète
isabelle et sa mère souhaite que le
message résonne jusqu'à l'assemblée
nationale et à la chambre des communes
ça me donne beaucoup d'espoir puis je
suis contente de voir que les gens se
mobilisent beaucoup
j'espère qu'ils vont se réveiller mon
sourire les yeux qui vont arrêter le
climato-scepticisme et s'engager dans
des projets concrets
ici catherine gauthier radio canada
montréal